hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen zu einem pferd das spiel
wurde so für die kommentare geschrieben
lukas spiel doch mal stars table der
säge spiel wir stars tables dass wir
können uns wohl hier eine reiterin
machen und mit der bestreiten wir dann
die kommende wettkämpfe
gebt mir mal kurz 2000 jahre ich mach
das mal schnell 2000 jahre später meine
damen und herren bitte begrüßen sie mit
mir du sagt kings sie schaut mal wir
können uns hier sogar einen namen
ausdenken das meine damen und herren ist
elena waterloos viele andere namen waren
tatsächlich schon vergeben wir kriegen
jetzt einfach noch weiter und unser
fährt sie tatsächlich eher aus wie ein
esel finde ich dass meine damen und
herren ist pferdchen summer rain
sommerregen weil es so aussieht als wäre
er ein
das sind rené lohs und summer rain will
klickt einfach auf bestätigen und
schauen mal was wir jetzt in den tollen
welten von dem spiel entdecken können du
kannst kleidung und ausrüstung wie du
nicht mehr braucht verkaufen um platz zu
schaffen und geld zu verdienen das ist
super wenn wir das eine katze auf einem
dings jetzt sagt gabler ganz viele
informationen wir kriegen einfach mal
überspringen und schauen ob wir den
leuten ihren ausgezeichnet mit dem kopf
am sprechen okay das heißt ich werde
jetzt einfach mal linken wie hat der
sänger hat gesprochen alter justin
bieber
ich bin kein genie kempten
ein neuer freund erhalten ich kann jetzt
auf marin security for mail servers
amaranth ist ja schon richtig krass
unterwegs oben ein gott wir haben hier
ja ganz viele andere spieler das ist
wohl mail mit der soll ich als wieso
reden die alle so kommen schnell ich bin
mary schön dich kennenzulernen kalaene
wusstest du dass ich die moorland stelle
zum ersten mal vor fünf jahren besucht
habt du bist ja ein richtig geiler
hängst du deiner schaufel da ich
versuche jetzt einfach mal nach draußen
zu reiten damit wir mal schauen wie groß
diese ganze welt ist bei mir wurde von
einem die kommentare gespielt das
abstützen ich komme hier nicht raus
irgendwie wie kriege ich da nichts - da
weg und juli kann es mir vielleicht
helfen scheiß auf pferde alter ich habe
einfach eine kuh bei allem respekt so
das spiel ist ja echt nice aber warum
kann ich mitten in einer kundin sein
bei mir hat es doch sehr viele bugs ich
soll mich bei einem mädel da hinten oder
evelyn waugh tokio hey du hast aber
einen schönen langen bart vielleicht
derzeit nur der arsch von sammrey mein
gott sie steckt in samarra topmodel
alles klar ich muss jetzt mal was ein
renner
sie sind über all diese kleinen teile wo
ich darüber müssen soll aber ich weiß
noch gar nicht wie man springen du hast
du nicht gelernt wie man springt
fahrräder können andere besser
absolviert umspringen zu lernen ja aber
wie ich tue ich das denn es ist so toll
ich laufe dieses rennen
und da mal rein wird vielleicht
weiterlaufen du hast verloren gibt nicht
auch beim nächsten mal klappt es
bestimmt vom summer rain diesmal
schaffen wir das bestimmt das ist doch
kann doch nicht so schwer sein hier du
bist doch auch ein tolles pferd
er ist eigentlich ein tolles pferd aber
sagt das team besser nicht lief in your
dreams and thinking kommt kalle rennen
beendete das rennen erfolgreich
absolviert china kann vielleicht sagen
was ich jetzt machen soll
das minus ist weg und mein gott wie nein
ich kann jetzt einfach draußen rumlaufen
und dadurch die natur laub sammeln wir
können so viel schaffen und leben nicht
frei sind los
wo bin ich hier gerne verwendet sahen
bis zu zehn fantasierten winterlied
rausgebracht
du hast deinen ersten stern gefunden
summer rain wurde mit den via hat etwas
angst aus es ist ein produkt der freunde
das ist das table
viele wollten dass ich das mal anfange
zu zocken wehrmacht tatsächlich spaß ich
weiß nicht weil wir so viele ja
geschrieben habe ich sollte mal
strawberry mountain china wir haben
wirklich so viele geschrieben ich sollte
mal zocken deswegen kennt ihr euch doch
bestimmt drin aus und können wir sagen
wie man da spaß dran hat wenn einige von
euch genug taschengeld bekommen können
sie mir auch irgendwas schenken in dem
spiel ich weiß nicht ob das möglich ist
aber die gibt euer geld lieber für döner
und center schocks aus so wie ich das
damals gemacht habe ich glaube wir haben
hier hinten sogar einen strahlungs auf
dem wir tatsächlich dann könnte ich
schwimmen alter das wasser ist so tief
während die beiden hier einen schönen
strand ausritt machen wenn man das ganze
überhaupt strand nennen kann würde ich
einfach mal sagen das ist das war von
dieser ersten folge stars der villa max
ernst erste folge weil ich wirklich bock
hab das noch das ein oder andere mal
weiterhin hoch zu laden wenn ihr mir den
tipps schreibt das zurich meine es ist
einfach in wien es ist so open world und
man kann so viel machen und ich liebe
mein pferd jetzt schon und dies ganz
schön schwarz angezogen wenn es euch
gefallen hat würden und sammeln und ich
luca uns über eine bewertung freuen und
wir sehen uns dann vielleicht im
nächsten teil wieder ciao